اشتراك اشتراك
إما
لدي مريض بهجت يعاني من الروماتيزم منذ 9 سنوات.
لديك مرض التهابي
مختلف الأدوية المضادة للروماتيزم
انا استخدمه لايجاده ايضا
أواجه صعوبة في استيراده من الخارج
الكثير من المتاعب بالنسبة له
اعيش صيدلية الصيدلة اتجول
لنأخذ بعض الأدوية
لا يمكنني استخدامه ، فالمرض سيء
يتطور المرض
أواجه مشكلة
zty
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
العاملين في مجال الصحة والخدمة الاجتماعية
إلا إذا كان راتبهم 10 فوق حد الحب
أنا أتطرق كثيرًا لدرجة أننا لا نستطيع التوافق
نحن هنا للتعبير عن ذلك
فوق خط الفقر بإنسانية
أريد أجرًا أساسيًا لأعيشه
[موسيقى]
هو
مشاعرك
[موسيقى]
موز
هذا النوع من تحديد مصالحنا
لا تقبل الموز
لكني أيضا رئيس تركيا
أنا ضد المصلحة كعضو في هذه المهمة.
كان يقول دائما منذ أتيت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هذا العلم